- I'm expecting an accurate
representation of our country.
- I'm not.
- I'm expecting to get a
lot of stereotypical ideas
of what Australian food is.
- I just keep hearing
about Blooming Onions.
("Flame and Smoke")
- [Voiceover] Steak.
- This is what we're going to
judge Outback Steakhouse on.
- It smells delicious.
- I actually just bent
the fork trying to cut it.
(laughing)
- This is a normal fork,
and this is Kelly's.
- And this is trying
Outback Steakhouse steak.
(steak hitting plate)
- This is good steak.
- This is not a good steak.
- It's so dry.
(knife crashing on plate)
- Stick to what you're good at.
- You ruined my day, America.
- Well, it smells like barbeque sauce.
- It's American barbeque sauce.
I can tell the difference.
- It's literally just chicken
with barbeque sauce on it.
- It's good but it's like not Australian.
- I'm just going to, I'm sorry.
(laughing)
- What's a good Australian sauce?
- A bit of tomato sauce.
- Tomato, not ketchup. Tomato.
- This is what we call
a prawn in Australia.
- Not a shrimp, it's a bloody prawn.
- It's a bloody prawn.
- Mmmmph
- What does it taste like a macaroon?
I'm sorry.
- Why is everything in
this country so sweet?
- Sweet.
- Everything we bite
into, we taste America.
- That was way too much
batter, but it was pretty good.
- That's a definite thumbs down.
- You've ruined the prawn.
- We would just do straight shimp.
We wouldn't have anything,
you'd maybe have like a little
bit of bread with butter.
- To the side, ok.
- Ribs aren't really a
big thing in Australia.
- No, they're definitely not.
- I'm starting to feel like
this Outback Steakhouse is like
- American Steakhouse.
- a Texas.
- Smells good. Smells like meat.
- Oh, I want to live in it.
- It's probably my favorite thing so far,
but it's not Australian.
- I'm probably going to
be crucified by saying
that this is actually really good.
- Like you don't really
get rib that often,
so this is like a treat.
- It's so good.
- What's this?
(laughing)
- That's a Bloomin' Onion.
- Is that hold on, hold on, wait.
- That's one onion?
- Oh, ick.
- Deep fried heaven.
- Oh, I've never seen any.
I can't even eat this.
- It's deep-fried onion.
(laughing)
- It looks like it's from Alien.
- Blaaah.
- It's blooming ridiculous.
- Get it out of your mouth while you can.
- It's actually pretty good.
- I kind of don't mind it in a weird way.
- I feel like if I had any more of that
I would regret it to the day I die.
- I can't stand it.
- All week people have been saying,
"You've got to have a blooming,
Bloomin' Onion or whatever
and you're going to love it,
you're going to love it."
How wrong they were.
- I'm really sad we're so
misrepresented right now.
- If you want to claim us for
this, we're happy with that.
- I didn't expect it to taste Australian,
but I expected it to taste ok.
- They've got all this American product
and they've just slapped a big
fake Australian kind of like
you're going to be
Australian now restaurant.
- I would like to know
who created the menu.
(didgeridoo music)
- The founders of Outback Steakhouse
have never been to Australia.
- It's a lie.
- Yeah (mumble).
- Didn't want to nip over
for a bit of research there?
- That makes sense now.
I mean it's ridiculous.
- That's like me opening
a Turkish restaurant.
- I know, that's what I'm
saying, of course we do.
- From everyone in Australia to the people
at Outback Steakhouse,
with all due respect
- Just jump on a plane.
- It's only 13 hours away?
- Ok just stop serving that onion thing.
- [Voiceover'] What's the slogan for
Outback Steakhouse again?
- [Phone message] Good day, mate.
Thanks for calling Outback
Steakhouse in Glendale.
We're located at 146 South
Brand Boulevard, press one.
- I think he's actually Australian.